[ __ ] flies is this guy in Boulder in
my Haywood I'm on a [ __ ] my nose is
wide open maybe 92 I'm walking around my
nose is wide open I'm don't calm I'm
getting a divorce and they're just
coming to me I got these people wanna do
scams and I'm running scams on them you
know but the only person I was running a
scam was I myself but there was one dude
no names he comes to me one day he's
like hey I need a pound of weed I gave
him like some lowball number 800 without
even showing him the power weed he gave
me the 800 I didn't see him for about
three weeks he came up to me what are
you talking about the guy was supposed
to bring it to the bar no I left I go ah
[ __ ] I gotta set this up all over again
I'm sorry I the guy lives up in the
[ __ ] mums I mean this one on for
[ __ ] years I owed this guy the 8 on
your fees then I went to New York and he
was part of the circle and outward so he
knew I had gone to New York and I was
dating that chick in the village I would
go around on Sundays I'm gonna have to
literally was swapping and spitting the
phone rings and it's this [ __ ] kid
looking frizzy [ __ ] eight hundred so
I started making money orders to pay my
child support but I would take the
receipt and write his name on it and
make a copy of it and mail it to him and
say I told you I sent you the [ __ ]
money or I told me this guy chased me
down talking about [ __ ] 96 God knows
when he's gonna show up
he hasn't even tortured me on social
media I wish you at least tortured me on
social media but never give careful what
you wish the moral of story is never
give up some of the og ain't hundred you
hunt them down to the [ __ ] day is
over right that's it and that's that
readings from podcast Ville it's Tuesday
the 17th of [ __ ] September the
church always brought to you by my
bookie listen if you found the yardstick
on the street would you pick it up but
would you keep walking like a [ __ ]
mutt nah you'd pick it up you take the
money right so why do you keep picking
winners and not bet not listen to me my
bookie is the way to go you bet you win
you get paid that's it and no matter how
you bet
the NFL season is the best [ __ ] time
of the year so double your first deposit
right now use promo code Church CH you
are CH to get a hundred percent bonus on
your initial deposit up to $1,000
you put a yardstick in you get a
yardstick in there they match it who the
[ __ ] is better than you visit my bookie
dot AG today that's my bookie dot AG and
don't forget to use promo code Church CH
you are CH when creating your
mother-fucking a cloud to claim that
[ __ ] Geddes my bookie dot AG also the
church would love to welcome kettle bell
kitchen kettlebell kitchen was started
by two army vets who also brothers by
the way their mission was to change
people's lives through making healthy
foods accessible eating healthy is on
everybody's mind right now
right or wrong whatever works for you
vegetarian keto hold dirty of Pelayo
these guys got it all right
listen they sent me a box and a
grass-fed steak the bison beef sliders
and the Cuban pork roast I'll tell you
right off the bat I'm not a fan of the
Bison beef but they were [ __ ]
delicious
the Cuban pork was delicious and the
grant grass-fed steak was delicious do
me a favor right now go to kettle bell
kitchen calm take a look at what they
got to offer these people even have a
telephone consultation nutritionist that
will [ __ ] talk to you about whatever
it is that you know people have plateaus
this is the service to go with if you're
into the quito vegetarian the whole
thirty of Pleo they have it go to kettle
bell kitchen dot-com right now all right
but what what the hell you waiting for
feed the champion in you with kettle
bell kitchens go to get a bell kitchen
calm and enter code Church CH you are CH
for $50 off your first to order for your
new customers that's $50 off your first
two orders at kettle bell kitchen calm
slash church the church is also brought
to you by the goods CBD Lyon listen
tinctures China's vapors
[ __ ] goomy's the best the best
yeah night I was running out four hours
of [ __ ] energy bag Italia I could
feel the CBD lion in me and the bounce
when I was going from Dallas to San
Antonio
well the CBD lying right now impressive
church and get 20% off your first
thought it's that [ __ ] simple all
right Lee kick this [ __ ] mule
Jesus Christ it's like my freshman year
this is it this Ted Nugent anyway Ric
Ocasek god bless you hope you're making
the journey nice and easy I like the
tank Dallas and San Antonio for [ __ ]
a great two shows great weekend listen
if you guys ain't got no energy my shows
gonna suck you guys went in there ready
to kill a [ __ ]
bo T is in San Antonio and Dallas I knew
I was in Texas as soon as I [ __ ]
landed you understand son
the warmth of tell you know when you
every city has a certain special
something Texas is just [ __ ]
sensational thank you very much if you
came out to one of the mother [ __ ]
bad-ass shows I wanted to talk to you
guys about something my mistake I made
on the podcast last week Lee had asked
me we were talking about quitting things
when you come to terms with whatever
you're doing isn't working or you think
is it working because sometimes you'll
think that something's not working right
and it's because you're not again you're
not giving it your 100% if you give
something 20 years a hundred percent you
still don't get nowhere it's time to
evaluate your game you know and you
evaluate it anyway every five years
you're valid it's something happens now
you got to bounce off that so it's
pretty much day-to-day and it's all
improvised but Lee asked me a question
he said if I thought there was somebody
who should give up and I said a name I'm
very sorry for giving out that name is
I'm in no position to crush anybody's
[ __ ] dream I just said in the
hypothetical way I sent a plan up if
that would have happened to me this is
what I do nobody said for her to quit
comedy what I meant for
or was to there's a different way to do
this sometimes you come to terms with
listen sometimes you're out here now way
you're on a [ __ ] roll you're popping
a show every year you're in the circle
everything goes alright and guess what
your [ __ ] mom has a heart attack
so what are you gonna do you know sell
hair like I'm on oh you gotta get on a
plane
you got to cancel a weekend you gotta go
see your [ __ ] mom and then while
you're there you understand that your
mom is sicker than what you anticipate
now what now you gotta get your
girlfriend to move into your house and
walk your dog every day and guess what
now you have to change up your game
nobody's saying that you have to quit
comedy but now you have to set up a plan
to how is this gonna make me work I
still gotta go on the road you know I'll
have to put auditions on tape and now
you're like I'm stuck here with Mom for
six eight or nine months or a year do
you quit no you just revamp your [ __ ]
game and you figure out a way to make it
work for you those are one that's one of
Jane this happens I'm talking about
whether your electrician whatever you're
always gonna have to make changes
somewhere along the line so you have to
improvise it's a day-to-day thing why do
you think I hate making plans when
people what are you doing next Thursday
I have no [ __ ] idea but I'm not
making plans till next Wednesday
because I don't know what I'm doing next
Thursday what if we make this whole plan
this whole hour on the books and I'm
popular audition Tuesday and I'm [ __ ]
so call me next Wednesday I will [ __ ]
he's the paint I live like a [ __ ]
animal do I like it no but that's the
way I have to live now I'm talking about
the suggestion that you come out here
and you give it your all what you think
is you're all for 20 years you don't get
to a certain place and you've gone
through your savings you've gone through
your inheritance you know things like
this yes
this time sister I haven't you say maybe
I made a bad call but out of all this I
got one gift what if I take that gift
and do something else with it well okay
then take your comedy and cruise ships
maybe a better for corporate events but
there's never you never quit you know
once a month I always get an email
from somebody who wants to be cured or a
tweet or something like a something
there you know hey I wish you didn't
abandon their daughter you know let me
tell you something there was every not
every decision I've made since I was a
kid was based on one thing when I was
about 11 he's hanging out at this guy's
house and one day he said remember you
always want to walk out on your feet and
crawl out on your knees I know exactly
what he meant by that at the age of 11
and it stuck with me and all the first
things I quit was basketball when I was
in love with it I was in love with it
but freshman he didn't start me and I
got turned around and ba ba ba ba I got
a lung infection and yes I got a bad
taste in my mouth and I quit do I regret
quitting today yes I did but before I
quit I was also very honest with myself
I took a look around on my family tree
and there was nobody really over [ __ ]
six with two in my tree I wasn't the
fastest guy in the world I could jump 40
inches and grab [ __ ] rebounds like a
[ __ ] but I knew this was gonna
be a hard uphill battle that at that age
I wasn't prepared to fight and I didn't
really want to go through the
disappointment so I continued to play
basketball I just didn't play it at a
high school level okay you know I quit a
thousand jobs every job wasn't good
thank God I found comedy ba ba ba ba and
then I had another situation pop into my
life like I told you last one got
married divorced it was a very big
mistake there's a lotta people that
didn't have to get hurt got hurt by our
actions when I went back I went back to
New York in 93 to regroup again like I
told you guys this is a life of
regrouping I had lost everything in the
divorce I was living with a friend of
mine I had my own bedroom I lived from
day to day there was days I just ate I
had a shoplift the cheese that comes in
the red wrapper the gula cheese I would
shoplift two of those and they're gonna
for a box of crackers a little container
fresh-squeezed orange juice and I live
off that all [ __ ] day you know and 90
the end of 92 I had it really [ __ ]
hard but it was all something like
created upon myself I had gone through
the credit cards I had written checks I
had bounced checks I had [ __ ] a car
that they were looking forward to get
repossessed and I hide in the garage it
was just a life of [ __ ] hell the
phone wouldn't stop ringing you know
this to go to an open mic or a [ __ ] a
comedy club and the comedy club owner
when you walks in gives you a piece of
paper and says hey you just got a call
and it's a 1-800 number in your mind
you're thinking it's HBO somebody saw
you from a [ __ ] TV show or someone you
call it throwing aids Marty what
happened to $40 you were gonna send me
out for the Discover card payment I mean
my life got to that [ __ ] point so and
my wife and I was not agreeing on things
at the time and the boyfriend was
getting involved I said you know what
let me just take a breather when you
want to take a breather in your life you
go right back to your home you walk the
streets you grew up in and it brings you
back and get your money it gets your
compass centered sometimes you have to
get your compass centered so I went back
then I got my top assented I kept doing
comedy and I learned one thing that in
New York the Open Mic world is a [ __ ]
jungle Colorado now that had been on the
Colorado scene in the New York scene
Colorado I was getting a lot more action
in Colorado it was a lot better level of
work yeah I could do three open mics in
one night but what good is it if it's
for a roomful of comics in Colorado I
was doing one show a night but it was
for a real audience and I was at the
third-year level so it was a big
difference going from this point to this
point after I regrouped in New York I
put a little money away I did a little
drug heist with my man
dreg oh god bless his soul and I gave me
a little bit of cash to go back to
Colorado with the intention of getting
an attorney fighting for my daughter and
doing comedy that was the plan and the
plan was sustained Colorado I was
not looking to be famous I was not
looking to be George Carlin or any other
hot comics and that day Jackie Flynn or
nothing like that I just wanted to be a
comic making a living live from city to
city do triple runs for the rest of my
life because I never thought I would be
that good to be at that level
I was very since I was very you know
that's the attitude I went back home to
Denver with TV go again we're just
because of your daughter did he think
about going other places no I went to
Denver because I want to be a father and
I went back to them because I knew that
when I went back to Denver first why
they don't have to kill myself is hard
to make a living
make a living I was making New York
there was a lot of movement in my life
and again going back to New York and
addictions New York you know the
addiction was fed on every block it was
too easy to get anything I get anything
at any time that's not good for me I
knew that wasn't good health it was I
gonna miss it [ __ ] yeah but in Colorado
you got to work a little harder but that
wasn't the decision in that the main
decision was to go back and be a father
first off I prayed to God that she had
cooled down a little bit that this 7th
8th month window had given her a chance
to step back and look at this for what
it was that maybe this guy just needs a
chance and but no as soon as I got back
we started a little money I put away
instead of it going to furniture in
clothes I went to an attorney's retainer
and for the next five 12 and three for
the next 18 months I lived in the state
of [ __ ] horror anger confusion and
shock not to mention I'm an open mic
I didn't quit because I was going
through all this [ __ ] with her and my
ex-wife I just kept doing comedy I knew
that the closer the more comrade did the
closer I get to my goal my goal was to
become a functioning human being
never mind the coke that was fine I had
accepted the addiction
I just wanted to be a human being that
worked pay those bills I wasn't looking
for much money I kept my nut low every
month I I finally learned the value of
keeping him not low when I got divorced
you know I didn't have a car payment
I had a pager I had a [ __ ] a4 hollow
apartment in Boulder
I mean Minot was basically eight hundred
a month nine hundred a month I could
[ __ ] him fine nine hundred dollars a
month that's my gift I could find that
hundred dollars a month so I did I
started doing well financially what's
well Joey well was 25 three thousand a
month that was you know hustling some of
drugs some cars and a little bit of
comedy picking up a five here a 10 here
a thirty here so this whole time I'm
making [ __ ] strides in my family life
I'm getting healthier and bolder I'm
walking I'm hiking I'm swimming at North
Hollywood pool look North North Boulder
YMCA whenever they have now I gotta let
bold or something I'm doing everything
in my life to cover the spread but what
kept getting worse was my relationship
with my ex-wife and my you know my
ex-wife's husband just kept getting
worse and worse worse and worse and it
would get good for a month and then it
would go downhill listen it was putting
a big [ __ ] stress on me it was big it
was putting a big stress on her but the
person that was getting stressed us by
this the most was my daughter Jacqueline
you know it's so funny now in hindsight
my daughter has girlfriends she's six
years old she's in the first grade and
one of her girlfriends his parents went
through a divorce you could see it in
the kid the kid is walking around angry
heartbroken throws fits it's horrible
but it's not her fault you know she's in
the middle of a divorce that's messy
they yell at each other
Curtis each other they don't talk to
each other so this leaks down into your
child I started to notice that a little
bit now there's
another side of the story they were
trying to frustrate me and break me they
were trying to frustrate me and break me
they were trying to frustrate me and
break me they were trying to push me for
me to make a bad move I saw this you
know when somebody does this to you
constantly and you're checking yourself
eventually one day you can't check
yourself no more you know we're all
[ __ ] human okay so the one day she
called me he called me a strict behind
my back and I found out now if it was
anybody else who call me a spirit I
would not even confront you because I
don't confront people all mystic aspect
you you using you telling me with your
words how ignorant you [ __ ] are so
now that 10 times I don't react to
racial slurs I never have has been first
of all they said it so much in Jersey I
just got [ __ ] used to it but I that
was an excuse for me to like this
[ __ ] huh now before I went into
this light-up mode there was three or
four months where I was living a
horrible life because I was preparing
their death I was designing their death
this is murder one this is not
involuntary manslaughter this is not
manslaughter I could tell you on this
microphone right now as a man that in
1995 I was designing my ex-wife and her
husband today is death it was on my mind
constantly and it was starting to get up
there with the comedy at that time my
whole passion was comedy and being a
father that was my passion I didn't have
money to stay healthy I lifted weights
at the house I swam at the Y I walked
you know it was a different way I stay
healthy because I was broke to be honest
here because 60% of my income went to
[ __ ] cocaine but my main objective
was riding doing those gene Perret work
books and I would do everything you know
in the daytime was I wasn't busy
hustling and I really really really want
the responsibility of being a father but
more I had stayed there I could see this
possibility was getting taken from me
every day it was getting taken from me
now there was a point where she wouldn't
tell the mother what we did a hard
afternoon in our weekends because she
was scared the mother would use it
against me so she stopped calling the
mother so the judge made me and her have
to write a letter together and hand it
to the mom we exchanged visitation there
were all these little things that I
could see that were affecting this
little [ __ ] five-year-old girl in a
way that was nominal child psychiatrist
but I know when people change I could
tell that whenever we made the exchange
she'd always put a head down and you
know it was just rough on her as a
five-year-old but in my mind I was still
designing their death I was designing
their debt and by designing that that
doesn't make them disappear and then I
would have to get custody and that
that's how when you have that much anger
in your heart and you have that much
frustration and whatever this is where
your head goes people talk about where
suicide comes from where's this cycle
you know I know it's Suicide Prevention
Month you this month or next month you
start getting these evil thoughts Maya
evil thoughts were not in harming myself
but I want no harm to people in the
worst way ever murder and they were
gonna disappear and my genius plot was
to tie him to a tree and rub honey I
don't let the Bears get him that was my
genius plot okay I mean another Vietnam
but right now I'd be [ __ ] getting the
electric chair but something didn't
sound right about it you know first off
I grew up without a mother horrible
existence finding out that your mother
got [ __ ] stabbed by your ex-husband
my ex why her ex-husband and your father
there's not a good way to [ __ ] grow
up that's not a good way to grow up you
know never mind that your mom is gone
and she was killed by your fault
that's not a smart way to [ __ ] grow
up and even though these little flashes
popped into my mind the the passion for
me the murder room was [ __ ] strong I
mean I looked back at the situation
delay and I and I'm in shock with these
words but they were frustrating me so
[ __ ] much I didn't know what what to
do how to start this how to hand this
and this whole time I got two felonies
you know what happens then you get a
third sounding they give you that
[ __ ] whatever wife of a felon
sentence and you get twenty five [ __ ]
years so I knew in Colorado I was
threatened done still [ __ ] skin so
then came the luckiest day in my life
really when you look at it he called me
a spring behind my back I drove down the
front of my daughter I raised my hand to
this [ __ ] guy you know would
satisfied the only person is satisfied
was my inner desire to get revenge after
the cops came and everything I looked
over and then the car was just pool and
a little five-year-old girl crying I
felt good for what I had done but now
that feeling had gone away once I saw
that little [ __ ] girl crying so from
that moment on for about a month I'd you
know now we're having a record I didn't
get to see it for two weeks then when I
did see it we kind of I remember her
saying to me that the morning after I
hit him she went downstairs for
breakfast but she was sitting there
looking at judge black eye and she
started giggling and yet on the outside
I giggled but they decide it broke my
heart because she didn't need to see
that she didn't need to see that at all
and here I was one of the [ __ ] kill
him she just saw me smack the guy and
now this she's reacting to it you know I
had to tell the house I apologized and I
apologized to him one day and the chops
the charges were dropped and then in the
middle of all that one day they [ __ ]
took me to court for something
completely irrelevant
and that's what I want they know I won
the [ __ ] case and I went off on her
and even though I would all father I
didn't feel [ __ ] good about it so now
I got all these [ __ ] signs telling me
this is not gonna [ __ ] work but then
life gave me the biggest sign of war I
got banned from the comedy works now
that was another month of thought now I
know how to change my life at that time
I was already doing triple ones and but
the goal was to work out of the comedy
works not McKelvey's not wit's end not
the other Club your goal at that time
was to be at the Comedy Works and my
foot was three corners in and I get
[ __ ] thrown out of there so now I'm
faced with the decision in this little
one-bedroom apartment with nothing in
the refrigerator but beer my decision
was what I really wanted out of this
life my decision was that I want to
[ __ ] go to jail because I didn't go
to jail that day that case got thrown up
but the direction where we were going
I was gonna go to jail and guess what at
one point that I accepted it I thought
[ __ ] it I'll get a fax machine sent then
I'll write jokes for Jay Leno and I make
$35 a day writing [ __ ] jokes good
luck this is how demented my mind was
when I think back at these times I have
to shake my head right then but I also
think of people that think about that
those type of thoughts in a different
way and they're do them to themselves
that's what that taught me especially
when you question somebody doing suicide
you start thinking to yourself like
Widow I was coming into suicide in a
different way because I was gonna go to
jail for the rest of my life that
suicide you beaten locked in a [ __ ]
cell the rest of your life yeah you
still got communication you still got TV
you still make [ __ ] in three pennies
an hour and you're still eating
but being in jail you have no life you
wasted a [ __ ] life you wasted our
life because of a [ __ ] impulsive
[ __ ] action that you did you waste
life and you probably ruin the lives of
three or four others so I know all these
things but I was faced with a tough
[ __ ] decision man I really wanted to
be a [ __ ] dad I really did but was
the desire of me being a dad to beat her
what did I really really really want to
be a dad that was the [ __ ] question
so I looked around my apartment I looked
at my [ __ ] refrigerator I was going
to the bank that night and put my ATM
card in and I couldn't even take a 20
out because I had like 18 dollars for
years I had an ATM card with 18 dollars
on it not even enough to take a [ __ ]
20 and I could buy like a slice of beets
if I was in a bind I looked around my
apartment I had a borrower car to pick
her up on Wednesdays or rent one and
borrow one to pick up on her to get her
one on the weekends you know I was
living this [ __ ] life you know I was
borrowing from Peter to pay Paul
was I really a [ __ ] father what if
what if I paid her back I I what if I
beat her in court
and got more visitation then I really
have the time to be a dad I wanted to be
a fireman I wanted to be a cop and it
broke my [ __ ] heart it broke my
[ __ ] heart but then the middle that
whole process I came up with something
else
I'm never gonna be her dad the way
things are going the way I want to be
her dad I'm just gonna be that man I'm
not gonna have a say in her first
community I'm not gonna happen
I mean at that point already she was
five I had never been invited to an
event if there was an event that this
kid had at school or either [ __ ]
reunion or at the Girl Scouts or
whatever the [ __ ] even involved with I
was never invited I was just a guy she
saw on Wednesday
and Saturdays that's what I thought like
and that's what it felt like at the time
so I had to decide what I wanted to do
and I came up with a decision I came up
with the same decision I came up with
1985 1985 I was [ __ ] lied to myself
for six years about this money I was
gonna get that my dad was gonna give me
I would lie to my friends and tell them
AHA [ __ ] any day now I'm getting a
half a mil or 28 mil there was nothing
coming to me the only thing I was gonna
get was [ __ ] dick that's all I was
going again I wasn't gonna get nothing
and finally in 85 I had the balls to
tell myself I'm lying to myself if the
money is gonna be there I'll get it
someday in the future if I got the money
coming to me I'll earn it I'll go out
there and earn it it'll come to me I'll
get a half well I thought I kept adding
these numbers that my stepfather's and
they gave me this amount of number in my
head and I just drove myself crazy with
it but I have when I got on that peoples
Express flight I'll never forget looking
at the pavement not in a Newark Airport
and saying you know I'm never gonna come
back here unless I got it unless I get
my life together unless I get my life
together and the next time three six
years to come back and the next time I
come back I'm gonna come back here a man
now I leave here like I left the [ __ ]
punk I still walked out of here on my
legs I didn't crawl here on my lease but
I walked out of here a [ __ ] Punk when
I made that decision that the money was
going to come to me it will come to me I
would earn at some point in my life and
I left it at that I never worried about
the money again never ever ever that I
worry about money again it was just
something that we used everyday I was
too involved with [ __ ] money and how
I wanted that quick [ __ ] pay
everybody wants that quick big chunk you
know I'm gonna get it you're not gonna
get it not the way you're thinking
so forget about it right now you're not
gonna get it not the way you're thinking
these people that think they gotta come
up with two hundred thousand thousand
three weeks they don't hit the lot
very few there's a way to do it but very
few could accomplish it I couldn't so
you work and you strangle out and today
here we are I'm 56 so I had to make the
same decision for Jackie myself and what
was right for the situation at hand I
cut a deal with myself I knew I had
nowhere to go immediately in Colorado I
could have spent another two or three is
development I knew that I knew that big
time before I can make a move I had put
those plans upon myself I knew was a
seven year until you get the [ __ ] out of
here
that's why I was just buying time but I
couldn't live there anymore because
something bad was gonna happen somewhere
along the line something bad was gonna
happen and it was gonna ruin all the
work I had put into comedy already so I
made a deal myself I said I'll tell you
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna go to
Seattle I'm gonna come back every couple
months and seeing my daughter I'm gonna
pay my child support I'm gonna call her
during the week I'm gonna set up a
schedule of quality during the week and
I'll come back in September to work to
be a sports betting service again and
you know razor and then do comedy on the
side let me just go to Seattle for a few
months to get my feet wet this situation
is not getting any better here it's
getting worse I'm having horrible
[ __ ] thoughts you know and let me
tell you something I was living with
these thoughts since Ike Christmas they
were haunting me guys haunted me haunted
me it changed who I was the only that
didn't change was that I didn't stop
doing comedy but if you came and spoke
to me when I was offstage
you knew there was something off because
after two minutes of talking to me I
would bring it to my ex-wife and my kids
and give me the hearbeat that you never
even asked for in your [ __ ] life I'm
sorry if I gave you an ear beatin that
time in my life but I gave on a lot of
them because it was all that was on my
mind I could talk about loss [ __ ] day
I'm man I was how she took this picture
Huber and sold it for $37 I was just
angry and now that they were trying to
take away my kid and I could see where
it was going and she had already made
offers to me well if she just signed the
paperwork give her a production you know
what to pay child support and you know
you lose all your rights that's what she
wanted from day one so we were that a
good place so my plan really really
really between losses family there was
no band of minion there was nothing the
plan was to come back in September as
soon as I left that fold schedule we
discussed on the phone the phone would
ring for hours there was no answer
I would leave messages to the top of the
thought I called the boss in Seattle I
asked him what he wanted me back and he
told me he wanted me back Labor Day
weekend the first weekend I football I
go how much time as I was already
experienced there's no reason to train
me and there's no reason to sit there
during preseason football I told I get
my timing back after a week or two and
then I get gone well I had never done a
featured spot before in my life and
always posted I had done a short feature
weekend in Michigan where I had to do 15
minutes but I had never done a 30-minute
spot I was calm I was in comedy for
years already and nobody had ever hired
me to do a 30-minute spot and it's all I
ever wanted this [ __ ] life was a
30-minute [ __ ] spot if I could just
do one [ __ ] plug on the spot I can
prove I'm a [ __ ] feature act I didn't
have any problem when I'm saying but I
could just prove to myself that because
with comedy art music
when you're first starting out it's the
little things you know when I talked to
Lisa mites I go how'd you do tonight do
strongly of oh I got an applause break
to Lee right now that's big that's what
keeps him waking up every day to go do
it again and try it again it's little
things that keep you going and then the
more you get into comedy you'll notice
or the more you get into art or plumbing
or whatever you'll notice that the gaps
for successful things happening widens
like now little things happen but they
don't happen every other week they start
happening once a month and it just
builds your doubt and doubt and doubt so
I had all these things going on I mean
it was a [ __ ] horrible feeling and
then one June bucking day I had already
met the stripper over Labor Memorial Day
weekend she was on her way to visit me
and like the first week of June
I picked the baby up and I took her
across the street there was I got a
little bicycle filled and all this [ __ ]
of it by North Boulder Park that and we
will around the block that's why when I
was taking a play at nice Boulder Park
it was right behind where I lived there
I took him to North Boulder parks and
while she took off on the bike I go
Jackie come back and she just been away
with Luke this [ __ ] helmet to the
point where I had to chase her she's
like no leave me alone no leave me alone
and finally when I did catch up to her
and stop Michael what's the matter
and she spit in my face at that moment I
knew that this was not going and
whatever thoughts I had will [ __ ]
confirmed I have to go away I have to do
something with my life I would when I
say do something with my life you did
not hear the word getting clean getting
clean was not my vocabulary I wanted to
do something with my life
so I could prove to myself and to my
daughter that I was a good person that I
wasn't the person that they were drawing
me out to be so when the stripper came
she stayed for a week she went to
Seattle her first phone call was when I
got here I looked in the paper and all
there is is calmly places she goes I
won't pass to calm me on the ground I
walked past giggles and it was like a
week of thinking about it and where I
was and the last couple visits of my
daughter what not the best visits ever
since that's back to John's face it was
just it was not happening you know I was
working by myself
she had the mother the boyfriend my her
grandmother and grandfather I had a lot
of people working against me at this
time but I wasn't giving them any
reasons to give me a chance to be honest
with you so I did the easiest thing in
the back of my mind I was and we go to
Seattle clean up two months tighten my
[ __ ] up maybe make a little money and
came back they didn't even come close I
put away enough money to leave on
September 5th I wasn't leaving on
September 3rd and then leave Carroll up
there which I knew she'd cheat on me a
thousand times I would leave Carroll up
there and I would come back in February
after football season but then something
will happen
I used to write her letters as a matter
of fact guys I have a box of letters
that I found that I made copies of over
the years I went to a after we went to
court a couple times we both had to go
see like a marriage counselor and [ __ ]
like that to report back to the court
and I explained to them my fears about
me my daughter being taken away from me
how little things were starting
and he was named one of them to me and I
go I then when I was in New York I would
mail her letters and she would tell me
she never got to lettuce and he goes
well then do yourself a favor before you
mail it or let him make a copy of it and
save him for him one day when you
reconnect with her show the letters with
the dates on the letters day you sent
them you know so I took his advice and
this is what I did you know and she had
said something to me like I sent her in
those days I don't know what was popular
some type of toy or something she wanted
I sent her a toy with the letter or
something and she said she didn't
receive it this is the seventh time I
had sent some and she didn't receive it
it was just getting too coincidental
and then I got a call from John Fox the
Booker this comedy underground and he
goes what he doing Labor Day weekend
when I go I'll be back to Boulder by
that he goes out it was a shame I was an
offer for the weekend that the comedy
underground but I said can they call you
back on one hour but mark me and I got
it I just got a double check with a date
and I hung up the phone he goes you have
one hour to call me back they paid $250
for five shows it was $50 I showed up in
30 minutes I'm Labor Day weekend the
headline it was Laurie Kilmartin who I
still see around town [ __ ] kick a
little tank she's a beautiful woman
the funny thing was that that required
thought I really had to think about hard
for a now and that's they came to me
that I was just never gonna be I wasn't
even [ __ ] father material who the
[ __ ] was I to be a father to a little
girl
I wasn't father [ __ ] material I was
never gonna get to be this girl's father
but I only have one shot at my dream I
only have one shot at this [ __ ] dream
that's it one shot I was 33 years old 32
years old my mind nothing else going on
but I was already making waves locally
and Edler
I was already getting high and as a
feature and then the people paying me at
bars to be
the guy before the headliner and then I
was starting at 50s and 40s and 65 75 s
I was already really earning wear
stripes had worked very very hard to get
the way I've gotten if he talked to an
open-mic Tomic they'll tell you how hard
it is to come up with 25 minutes and and
and now you're not doing open my snow
morning I wasn't doing in New York I was
doing laundry mats and [ __ ] hamburger
Harry's and all this [ __ ] now is doing
bars in Denver with 80 90 people with a
real headliner that the bar paid 200
bucks done our [ __ ] Wednesday night
or a Tuesday night on an off night so I
was just working my ass off and here I
got a call and I had to decide I said
okay what I'll do is I'll take the
feature week and then I'll leave or I'll
after that and right after the feature
week for some reason John Fox came up to
the weekend watch really knows hey I
just want to ask you do you want to do
the Seattle comedy competition so here I
was another tough decision was the case
the a no Comedy Competition it's in
November you know so I stayed and did
the Seattle Comedy Competition I did the
sixth was I ready to go back I got beat
by he should Taylor she took the fifth
was I prepared to go back to Boulder or
whatever yeah I was gonna go back to the
holidays but then I got arrested I got a
rest of the Seattle for domestic
violence assault you know some stupid
[ __ ] at a bar with the strippers ex
[ __ ] boyfriend so they called it
domestic violence on Maris and that is
and ice and jail for 30 days and my
ex-wife found out about that I had a
call over and she had accept the charges
collect call I had Josh wolf
send my daughter at any bet hey Josh
wolf the [ __ ] send my daughter or
white teddy bear and Josh wolf did him
then I had to call a friend of mine in
Boulder to call my wife to let him know
that she was in
expect the collect call from me that I
was an agile job [ __ ] thing up in
Seattle when she asked me what you got
arrested for and I told her she said
well doesn't look like he really really
ever get this kid and she giggled and I
knew what time it was so there was no
abandonment at all and no point I think
maybe once after that I went back to
Boulder the visitor I booked the plane I
flew from SeaTac Airport into Denver and
I ran to the car I borrowed a friend of
Mines credit card went to the car and
those days you can use some of these
card and I went to Boulder and I stayed
on a friend's floor and I was there for
five days you know many times I saw my
daughter in five days zero I would do
that every six months and three visits
you know how many times I saw zero there
was always an excuse there was always
you have to hire an attorney and start
from scratch again there was always
something there was no abandonment and
then while I was in Seattle at some
point I got a call one day that she's
moving to England because a stepfather
got a job in [ __ ] England and then I
didn't have contact with her and then I
moved to LA and that's when we started
contact there was never never ever know
abandonment of guys so before you try to
[ __ ] be cute and throw that jab at me
there was never no abandonment I never
had nothing to work with in the first
place
the only thing I had that was going for
me was the comedy and even though my
mind was the dark place and my heart was
broken and I was sad I would force
myself to go on [ __ ] stage I remember
the pain I was going through then dug up
the pain from my mother I was living
with triple [ __ ] pain and I would
still smoke a joint I'd cry a little bit
smoke a joint and I would force myself
to go on [ __ ] stage you know I
accepted it for what it was I finally
got a hold of her in England we spoke a
couple times and then when she moved
back to the states it was Radio [ __ ]
Sal
select a few messages and there was
radio silence a letter in the mail one
day saying that I owed ninety two
thousand dollars to child support what
they didn't know what my ex-wife was
accounted I didn't have it back to
channel I would have to check cash all
my checks in a check cashing place on
Whitley and how he was still there I
know everybody I was friends with
everybody I used to go hey he's to go
behind the glass that's how much they
knew me and I uh I looked at the bill
and I said I hadn't paid child support
I'm like [ __ ] a year and my wife you
know was [ __ ] the real deal she's
like I see you mail the money all this
how the [ __ ] is she get because I was
mailing it to a house I was supposed to
be mail him to some p.o box and Boulder
that was legit and they would kind of
check and send it to her
so I was sending another money so
obviously she said she didn't get the
money she said she had never gotten the
money not that plan she didn't need the
money she was just taking those and
ripped them up I didn't even bother
checking that cache should I check
checking the things we went back to the
check cashing place check cashing place
nothing said none of those money honest
I've ever been cashed so what we did was
we got a list of the money orders that
my wife drew up an affidavit and we got
a notary Republic and we had ascended
the [ __ ] mold the Child Services and
then they knocked off the [ __ ] 90
thousand off the bill they accused my
wife or some [ __ ]
and that that's what I live with but
then something really weird happened
I got BASEketball I got a couple movies
and I wouldn't call to brag I just
brought that by this time that would be
enough to had proved myself to that that
I had changed
he was always snorting coke there was no
arrest there was nothing I was living in
Los Angeles for all they knew you know I
was living with pain that's what was
that's what had me [ __ ] doing Laurie
night and all that
it was living with pain or what I had
done and guilt uh and then something
happened in 2004 I booked the [ __ ]
along this yard did a couple pictures on
set bro like a two or three page letter
you know and I sent the [ __ ] letter
and I called him again there was no
[ __ ] response so the dream worked out
for me a Mayan I got the way I had to go
the only part of the dream was me
winning her over at the end you know and
I don't I don't know I hope you guys
don't understand that it's just because
I got three or four movies I acted when
hero who wasn't because of the movies I
wanted her to know that change in my
life around
and I had worked hard to get to where
I'd got but by that time it was too late
our relationship was damaged goods and
then came another series of more pain
and more addiction and more whatever and
then I think after writing about it for
a year in journals and notebooks from
whatnot
I finally loosened up the pain and I
loosened up the addiction and I came to
terms of what I had and after about two
years of being clean I started taking
around now I was the complete person now
and said dual comedy wasn't successful
by no means but I was doing comedy I'd
been in a few movies I had done the work
and I was clean it was time to me to
confront though like a man and whatever
by confronting I don't want no problems
I did not want to stop her at school
embarrass her and again to an argument I
just reached out but before I reached
out this time I wanted to confirm some
suspicions so suspicious so I called a
few friends of mine they referred me to
a private investigator I gave the
private investigator retainer and I had
him confirmed my suspicions and my
suspicions were all true you know even
when they had her in high school they
had her living out by Truman University
wherever the [ __ ] that is is that's
where she went to school was a Truman
University so I had given up that
address so I couldn't hunt it down in
Colorado the first thing the guy said to
me was Dave Trott they're trying to hire
and they hit her a really good doesn't
have a Facebook page has a Twitter page
private no tweets no nothing I've sent
the endless tweets analyst whatever the
relationship just like the foot and
there was nothing I can do about it but
I wanted to know what I believed in my
heart fully and I wanted you guys to
understand who I am in my heart with
this situation I never abandoned that
child if you know anything about me and
my loyalty issues to my friends in
Jersey you know a little abandoned
nobody
I'm the Bandon anybody unless you
abandon yourself from me and that's
exactly what she did and you guys
haven't you checked my Twitter
I hit her on Twitter every three months
I thought of calling them well the last
Monday on the 30th anniversary between
you and I and I said what would I get
from it a joke to feel bad or how to say
something bad for me the ones soaked up
you know what in some situations you
have let dogs lie you know I think the
the fourth or the second step of a a is
to call all the people you hurt and
apologize til this day even in my
personal life
I apologized to as many people as I
could there's still a few people that an
apology isn't really gonna change what
happened to our relationship because I
ruined what I did the action that I did
so that's how I live with myself today I
lived with myself that I knew that I
didn't abandon her I did the commitment
of my child support and I tried
I still remember going to Houston for
the first time and there was a [ __ ]
thing that was really popular that like
a bunch of these little stuffed animals
they have an all difference horses
beanie babies beanie babies
they were rare ones people will collect
his item and she won the specific beanie
baby and Lee Italian I don't want to get
on no bosses I was no know I was so
[ __ ] broke as a feature act that I
hopped on a bus and went across town to
its different mall before my flight just
to get her this little beanie baby white
horse or whatever and again I sent it
and something was to happen to it the
mail we never got it so it was always
something I saw I never gave up and in
my heart I never gave up hey it's not
for it's not my fault that a 50 God
decided to give me another chance and
draw a daughter my way it's not my
[ __ ] fault
so I guess the void that was left by
Jacqueline is now filled by mercy my
ex-wife got what she wanted she wanted
me to be away from her and to be raised
without me in her life and for her to
raise her on her own with another man
and to start a family and be a different
human being and my wife got that and
gets like that I got the career that I
wanted I got off cocaine I got so all
parties involved were happy you and I
both know that's not the truth you and I
both know there's gonna be blowback at
my daughter mom my daughter might not be
today it might not be tomorrow but
that's some day that skeleton is you
sweep in the closet will come back to
bite you in the ass they always do
that's why you gotta check out that's
why you gotta check on your skeletons
from time to time because you don't want
them checking on you so how long can she
walk around knowing that her real father
is out there you understand me so
somewhere along the line they're gonna
pay for this and also because this comes
back to bite you in the ass later when
you abandon the child or you don't
abandon the child you abandoned somebody
you know they don't want me to contact
her or they don't you know I don't have
a restraining order nothing like that I
get on a plane right now I don't
where she lives I know exactly where she
works I know where she sells real estate
I get on a plane today and stalk her and
tell them what I'm telling you people I
do not want to do that that would that
would just create more of a [ __ ] that
would just fit into the illusion that
they think this is what they want me to
do to really embarrass myself for her to
call the cops on me this is what they
bain't me to do by doing what they're
doing me I'm old enough to know that
sometimes you gotta plant the seed and
let it [ __ ] grow and watch it
keep your on that water it feed it make
sure it has sunlight and see where it
ends up I know this now at them at this
age I wouldn't want to not be a father
now because I want to go to Denver and
stab somebody all those feelings of God
away and they're long gone the anger the
frustration the confusion about all this
it's kind of way I made peace with it so
before you think you're being cute next
time you throw a message at me about
Amanda Lee murder Jackie if you know
anything about me
I will abandon anything 28 years
I don't abandon calmly I mean George
Carla dense key Tammy Holloway James V a
Scalise Devo you know [ __ ] year lubes
you know the gallows that all these
people it's been 40 something years that
my loyalty still stands to them I'm very
hurt because I don't speak to my
daughter I would love to have her in my
life I don't think we could be that
close I don't think we could repair I
think would be a slow process you know
but just to have her call or check in
let me know what she feeling if I could
help her out with anything that would be
a great feeling to but fit today we'll
leave it where it is why okay I
understand what you're saying everything
you're saying but people say crazy [ __ ]
to you
online in person all the time why did
this one strike a nerve it made me laugh
it made me laugh that there's people
walking around that you know with all
the stories that telling him I'll be the
fiend and [ __ ] and Indians and
generations [ __ ] kidnapping people a
trunk of a car that that's what you
would pick you know that's the most
hurtful thing you could say 20 years ago
was the most hurtful thing that you
could say to me not now when you say a
statement like that to me today
like the guy who said the other day I
told him I would hate to be him because
how how angry do you have to be deep
down inside to make that state that
somebody maybe was having a bad day baby
his wife left him for the Mexican
lawnmower man who knows but for somebody
to make that statement when we were
talking about something completely
different something completely different
he could have attacked me at 20
different levels that's the level he
thought I and I even answer them
correctly I feel like I said - I didn't
say [ __ ] you were sucking my dick a
nothing because I felt that bad for I
felt that if that's where his head is
that jesus [ __ ] christ it's a
Thursday morning Thursday way and then I
looked at his profile pic chemical that
show he was a [ __ ] stiff but that
doesn't matter
me being that gun at Thursday morning
I'm not even responding to me you know
at that age I'm not even responding to
me I'm going on getting my dick sucked
I'm making money I'm jumping up and down
he ain't doing that obviously he's
finding the time to be spiteful all
right so we it's like Steve Simone says
all you can do is pray for those
[ __ ] that's all you could
[ __ ] do listen
it's Tuesday get your [ __ ] together it's
the [ __ ] 17th of the month erases
before you know it's gonna be Halloween
and when you wake up there's gonna be
[ __ ] Christmas advertising because a
nobody makes money selling Turkish
Halloween candies already out Halloween
[ __ ] candies around oh you got I know
you got I know you it tastes just the
first batch yeah sure just a minute
that's good for the kids you don't want
any upset but that's it and that's that
that's your Tuesday [ __ ] morning
podcast or late Monday night I was
[ __ ] you want to use it I just wanted to
get that out and let you know where I
was in my world because that's what I've
you know I've been I've been writing
this [ __ ] out lately because in between
the book and the one-man show for a lot
of people don't know this Wednesday at
the Comi so it's already sold out the
third Wednesday of every month I'm gonna
go up there I mean right now I think I
can alter the last I think I got some
like 40-something stories written out
all right in a book at the same time and
I think I got up to 88 stories that I
have to move around and find where they
work at this one-man show so September
October November and December the third
Sunday of every Wednesday of every month
at 8 o'clock or 7:30 I checked a web
site I will be working out my one-man
show it's just a night of [ __ ]
stories chronological I'm gonna mix it
around I got [ __ ] I want to try so it's
just gonna be a workshop I really wanted
to do it the world-famous Comedy Store
what my intentions is with this workshop
is to get it
tying it down by maybe March or April
and then maybe put it somewhere in New
York City for like a three week run off
off-broadway that's what I'd like to do
I've always liked that idea I suggested
this to Richard Jamie because he was
such a great storyteller
I thought he could wipe I thought he
could [ __ ] pick up like his arm on
wipe his ass with him so now instead of
Jenny doing it God rest his soul I'm
gonna put my money where my mouth is and
I'm gonna try the same [ __ ] thing
hopefully in a few weeks by doing that
the store in fact I had a calling guys
rag I'll pick up a director to help me
with a couple things you know this first
three months isn't gonna be moved little
lights or is that you would darkness no
that [ __ ] is just gonna be a fat [ __ ]
telling stories someone gonna be funny
someone gonna make you cry suddenly
gonna make your [ __ ] jaw drop and
eventually we'll put them all together
and then we'll [ __ ] put it on off off
off off off off Broadway and work
ourselves to Broadway right together as
a
Podcast and the church family is how you
do it so I appreciate all your
[ __ ] support again I had a
great time in Texas this weekend
majestic theatre was beautiful
and the Aztec theatre was sensational it
was a taco truck outside the Aztec Dino
so we think they got us three [ __ ]
tacos there were tremendous with salsa a
lot of lettuce it was just a great
[ __ ] weekend listen you never go
wrong in Texas but next up is another
city or I never [ __ ] go wrong and
that's Chicago baby boy we're doing the
Chicago Tina Kate Quigley deand or Izzy
we're going in there we're gonna like
that [ __ ] town on fire edible juice
vapors cake wigglers gonna show her
monkey it's gonna be [ __ ] tremendous
even if I got to shoot a bottle rocket
out of it we're doing something but
quite clearly was monkey that weekend
it's over she's [ __ ] roller skate
with a bikini and we're doing something
you're gonna know we get to town when we
get to town so go to Chicago Peter calm
whatever the [ __ ] it is Chicago theater
do not go to these other companies some
girl came up to me and broke my heart
and [ __ ] whatever she said she paid for
allowance for tickets at some place if
you pay any more than $35 from me
without the [ __ ] ticket like without
this whatever service the service free
listen please don't do that please don't
do that I'll be back I'll be back you
see me on the schedule and improv to get
a ticket and get a plane and spend the
weekend what you love her and come down
and make me one of the things you want
to see but do not pay oversized I am NOT
worth to one of ours it is not worth it
do not put more money in a scalpers hand
than when you're putting in my [ __ ]
hand why would you do something like
that do not I'm telling you right now
when it's sold that it's sold that don't
go little secondary [ __ ] websites cuz
they just want to rob you I don't get
none from them my agent doesn't get none
from that nobody makes a [ __ ] dime
from that so either you pay the twenty
eight fifty plus the service fee or the
32 plus the service fee you know I don't
keep my tickets over $35 what they do in
Vegas is completely different you know
Vegas everybody's tickets a [ __ ] 80
[ __ ] dollars so whatever Treasure
Island does I'm
I'll be there for February 28th but I'm
not worried about that what I'm telling
you [ __ ] is next Friday at 27
Chicago [ __ ] Deena but now to a
word from our sponsors first off
listen great [ __ ] first week of
football great second week of football
now you're going to do your [ __ ]
third week you're scratching your head
Joey I could have won again last week
you're full of [ __ ] [ __ ] my book it's
fast it's easy and they pay when you win
let's race it where your betting is as
important as who you bet not if you're
trying to bet on the NFL baseball MMA
whatever my book he's got it I wouldn't
be telling you guys to bet with them if
they weren't the best so do the smart
thing if you're gonna bet this football
season back with my bookie I mean did
you know you can bet on games after
kickoff no if by the second half it
looks like your bets gonna lose you can
always just take the other side
my bookie dot AG does those little
things if you're the kind of guy that
likes to bet a little one a lot try a
parlay there's my bookie if all your
picks come true you multiply your
winnings and know I'm and no matter how
your bet the NFL season is the best time
here this is it right now you got this
you gotta be a basketball college
basketball coming at the [ __ ] playoffs
you got a hockey my bookie will fulfill
your [ __ ] gambling fantasies or
whatever the [ __ ] you like to do double
your first deposit right now today it's
Monday night we got two games tonight
know what yeah two games tonight I think
use promo code Church to get you 100
hundred percent bonus on your initial
deposit up to $1,000 what are we talking
about here I'm gonna double your money
today just go to my bookie dad AG today
that's my bookie
grab a [ __ ] pen mo mo my B Oh Oh kie
dot AG and don't forget to use promo
code Church when you're creating your
account to claim the bonus my bookie dot
AG you play you win you get paid
you understand me don't forget they're
running a contest five teams you got to
pick every week $100 at the end of the
season whoever has more points gets a
hundred thousand [ __ ] dollars
so go to my booking dal AG right now
hey at the beginning I talked to you
guys about a new sponsor were working
with kettle bell kitchen they're really
different that this has anybody else
that's approached me is I like the
telephone consultation with a
nutritionist I mean listen kettle bell
kitchen their mission is to change
people's lives through making healthy
food more accessible eating healthy is
on everybody's mind right now what when
and how much eat it's hard to know where
to start plus meal planning and prep is
time consuming you don't want to spend
that type of you don't want to spend
your entire Sunday chopping carrots and
roasted chicken breasts do you kettle
bell kitchen helps you stay on your diet
by taking out the hassle of shopping and
cooking these meals come right to you
twice per week for optimal freshness
plus you'll never get bored because they
offer personalized menus whatever works
for you vegetarian keto whole dirty
Pelayo they got it you can even silt
them by your calorie fart fat and
carbonate so you get exactly the right
foods for your unique needs that's what
I'm talking about kettle bell kitchen
all their meals are free of dairy soy
and artificial sweeteners and made from
ingredients that are naturally
gluten-free and unlike other meal boxes
you can order one meal at a time or sign
up for a plan you can change it up any
time no learn some long-term contracts
this week they had a tremendous menu now
I can't find it they sent me when they
first reached out to me they sent me
some tremendous stuff all right they
sent me the grass-fed steak
the bison beef sliders and the Cuban
pork roast listen my wife and I
insatiable they were sensational all
their meals like I said a free of dairy
soy artificial
three sweetness and a made from
ingredients at all naturally grew to
three so what are you waiting for what
the hell you waiting for you've been
thinking and how can I go on one of
these diets and for it to be effective
here it is
feed the champion in you with kettle
bell kitchen you understand me hold on
one second hold on one second let me
tell you what they got a good menu this
weekend I wasn't crazy athlete chicken
parm buffalo turkey burger Moroccan beef
burgers that's the menu this week right
now go to kettle bell kitchen calm and
at the coat Church CH you are CH the $50
off your first two orders for new
customers that's fifty hours off your
first two orders at kettle bell kitchen
dot-com use cold word church CH you are
CH also you know I love these guys they
keep me flying fresh they keep me listen
the tension and the gummi bears a second
to [ __ ] nut anybody I drop a
bottle of tincture off even Harvey's
father was like I don't know what's in
there
but I've been well you know the Harry's
father took a trip and hiked up the
column and jari was looking
something-something raizy
he's 80 [ __ ] years old CBD line is
the way to go listen go to CBD line calm
look at their third party lab results
you're gonna be [ __ ] amazed
look at how they categorize everything
how they care about that product this
isn't something you buy at a liquor
store or some [ __ ] hair store or a
barber CBD line calm go to that website
right now they're gonna change your
[ __ ] life okay see and they listen
whatever you wanna do you want to smoke
it with shadow they got it you want to
smoke it with a vapor they got it you
want to [ __ ] eat it with a tank
should put it under your tongue like
uncle Joey literally last night I put
5,000 milligrams under my tongue I went
to bed 11:30 I woke up a [ __ ] 7:30
this morning okay I got up to pee at
7:30 I didn't take that bottle on the
road with me I took their 250 milligrams
and even that CBD line is second turn
I'm gonna see me beeline calm right now
look at their second party third party
lab results for yourself on the way out
of checkout after you buy a bow without
tension put on your tongue
put in code word Church CH you are CH
and get 20% off the Liberty house again
I want to thank you guys I want you to
have a great weekend
a great week we'll be back either
Wednesday at Thursday morning my
surprises week and that's it and that's
that motherfucker's don't forget the
Chicago theater September 27th 8:00 p.m.
cake Quigley bean del Rizzy who the [ __ ]
you think you're dealing with kick this
melee Ric Ocasek rest in peace I love
you